close later
on what the hell is that Mary Kish oh my
God Comic Con hello welcome to the lobby
GS weekly hang Tuesday at 2 p.m. Pacific
right here on the gamespot.com my name
is Dan dwire this is my last time on the
show for a couple weeks so we're just
going to have fun we're going to play a
game that I wanted to come out for years
which eventually came out it's called
Firefall also the last of us that's why
Tomic Shay is here hey Chris Waters hey
Danny how was ComiCon ComicCon was
delightful uh I got to do some game
demos got to watch the videos that Mary
and Warner and Anna brought back from
like the cool stuff happening at ComiCon
with the costumes and the what games
were at Comicon costumes what games were
at ComiCon games that were at ComiCon
that were like playable on the show
floor or that like were on the Game Spot
stage that were on the Game Spot stage
we had Disney infinity Skylanders Trap
Team Phoenix rage War Machine
tactics another
one well we're going to hear more Comic
Con news later onw when Peter BR and
Justin I purged my memory of all that
stuff on the the stage but right now
yeah a new video game came out I know
it's the summer no new games come out
right except Firefall because it's like
it's been in development since the dawn
of time but this year we're very lucky
to have a new game from Naughty Dog cuz
it's been so long since they've made
Uncharted 3 new Naughty Dog game The
Last of Us is finally out the Last of Us
remastered oh Tom reviewed it last year
but that wasn't actually The Last of Us
the thing that was the PS3 beta for it
actual version for The Last of Us
finally finally here a $60 Early Access
and you can do slow pan selfies you can
do like Michael Bay 36 shots that's what
they added to this game this is The Last
of Us
remastered the PlayStation 4 version of
The Last of Us which also has the DLC
which is that what we're playing at the
moment yes so this is Left Behind uh I'm
going to play it Tom's going to talk
about it I will also probably say words
about it it's fraking fantastic this is
photo mode by the way okay which is a
weird I don't I don't know when they
added this in but like you do this at
any time yeah in ch the DLC do you know
if you can do it in the main game um
probably I don't know
no you can do it in the main game that
was one of the things they added for the
remasterings can you pause it right when
Joel is getting his like tendon torn out
of his neck remember that remember that
one you just hit it right there that
death condition he like I don't know if
you can do it any time yeah I mean I
just did it cut here but I'm not allowed
to I can't free camera move okay uh so I
could probably take I don't actually
know how you take a photo photo yes I
will I will not do photo mod but that is
is that like the only sort of extra in
terms of just base level mechanics what
is new in this release is that all you
can think of well it has it has some of
the
DLC from The Last of Us included and of
course like the multiplayer all the
multiplayer maps that were DLC are in
here not all of the like paid DLC stuff
where you could like buy
a customization thing or perk thing or a
weapon not all that's in there but uh
all the sort of free updates they did
are also in here Tom this is one of your
favorite games uh last year yeah uh it
is it is really it was really great
would you go back and play this I don't
know I was getting really like watching
Carol cuz she reviewed it for us
watching her in the combat was making me
a little anxious again remember first uh
so I don't know if I would go back I
love I love left behind though so I will
play that on the PS4 okay H Left Behind
obviously that DLC we won't talk any
spoilers here but that happens this Happ
we're playing it right now this is Left
Behind which comes packed in with Last
of Us remastered just to clarify yeah
yeah but is this it's it's a separate
option on the menu it's not just blended
into the story or anything yes and you
should play it after you play the main
campaign we are playing parts that take
place before the main campaign ever
starts and they are not spoilery there
are parts that are not that way yeah oh
what's up typhoon Blitz if you have any
questions at all uh by all means uh
please let us know in the Gamespot
comments or the twit shot if comes in
with a question on Twitch is Left Behind
also enhanced uh apart from the 60
frames per second has all that graphical
touch stuff uh been laid on to DLC as
well oh yeah they it got the same the
same treatment and it doesn't need to be
enhanced too much cuz this this is this
game is looks so good this is my
favorite game of 2014 so far left behind
even if it isn't technically a game
because it's DLC when did it it came
back back in February March right it
came out Valentine's Day oh really yeah
Happy Valentine's Day and is go play The
Last of Us a bunch without getting into
it too much uh ma is there a lot of is
there a lot less killing stuff in Left
Behind yes there is a lot less and what
is in there is all very important I know
okay what is in The Killing part or in
the other part in the combat stuff is
very important it's not it doesn't have
any kind of like filler or fighting just
for the sake of fighting yeah it's it's
very strongly ties into who Ellie is and
who she's becoming and the world she's
in and stuff all of it how much should
the single player of you play ch
all of it no no no I mean on the PS4
since it's none of it none of it oh
really I haven't played any of the
single player campaign uh I mean I've
been at ComiCon that's good point uh but
I have play I've played a little bit
into the last of us this are the sorry
left behind this is not right at the
beginning uh so during this whole part
you're like you're going to get blit you
accepted it I I did not accept it what
oh yeah tastes like ass oh man that was
horrible hey you do some cheers Winston
great this is during this part you're
like reunited with Riley who's your uh B
Dog from Call of Duty yes Jesus she
transforms she's an anamorph great and
uh she can do that no so you're
basically exploring the mall you're sort
of Riley comes back and you're not too
happy with her and like you guys go to
check out the mall CU she's got
something to show you and during this
whole part you're you know there's no
clickers jumping out at you during this
part it's like you're just getting rip
[__] you're just getting drunk and
you're like observing the environment
you've seen prompts that are come that
have come up wait you just you just get
drunk and observe the environment it's
like this is your weekends this is my
weekend this reminds me of when I used
to break into the mall with my friends
and get rip [__] and observe the
environment I was waiting for somebody
to make that video game I observe the
environment but you've seen there's like
prompts that you can like ask her about
something or like bring up a
conversation topic and like a lot of
this part is just kind of
what like character development it's
like two friends like reconnecting and
the things it's at a different pace yeah
yeah what's interesting though is that
it also does take the mechanics that you
know from the combat like throwing
bricks and shooting guns and it puts
that in getting drunk in yeah getting
drunk and it puts them like so you do
things slightly different but it's the
same mechanics that furthers their
friendship so it's like a really cool
way that you're an active participant in
this in this relationship I I saw the um
yeah she was kind of like walking along
the edge of the potted plants in the
same way that you would if you on one of
the beams yeah supposed to do something
now but I wasn't paying attention to
what they're saying you know you haven't
played The Last of Us in I'm guessing
since it came out just like without
Graphics comparisons of side by side is
there anything in this that like
immediately pops out of you because the
last of us was a pretty fantastic
looking game on PlayStation three it
really was uh I don't know Tom if you've
watched a little bit more of it but I
like in the cut scenes it
looks so they've done something in the
cut scenes I'm not exactly sure what it
is but like it it looks a little
smoother and it sort of towed that line
of like is it too smooth like my eye was
like wait am I seeing something odd here
I don't know did you get that sensation
at all Tom no I I I honestly don't see
the difference I didn't watch our I
didn't watch we have a video that's
showing the difference you can straight
see it when it's side by side when it's
not side cuz I was watching Carrow play
a lot over shoulder and I I really
couldn't see and I was watching you play
multiplayer before we started I I can't
I can't tell the difference like if you
told me it was a PS3 game i' like yeah
if you told me it a PS4 game I'd say
yeah like I'm really I'm easily
persuaded so if if you're like if you've
played the game before is the the
remastered Graphics aren't like you got
to come back and play it for the super
souped up visual I think I had the same
reaction cuz I reviewed Tomb Raider this
year after loving it last year I think I
had a similar reaction where it didn't
really jump out where I was like oh this
is completely different they didn't
really I didn't have that feeling I'm
not really some of these games are so
good where you kind of any any excuse to
come back and play them again is is
maybe gupi R is asking a question many
people are how much fighting is in this
DLC there's probably only three or four
combat encounters okay long yeah two
hours three hours something like that
yeah like three hours I would say 3
hours this is the only single player DLC
that nauy dog have planned right like
they're yes they're just doing
multiplayer stuff only single player DLC
they've ever done oh really ever so none
for yeah none for Uncharted all mon
there yeah they're done with DLC now
that's it they're done with all the maps
DLC oh yeah check out my sweet wolf mask
oh man I love the scene the scene's
Great Dan have you played this I've not
played the DLC you got to play the DLC
and then we can talk about the DLC it's
so good David jaffy sign off so good
what are you doing I don't know I think
I'm supposed to make a
roar
watch Cutting Loose man you don't get
you don't get to cut loose when you're a
kid in the you do and you drink bottles
of bum wine that you found in this
busted ass Mall you drink old bum wine
and play dress up yeah put that one on
yep of course put that weird Mark Cy
mask on I like how they like they're
kind of what did you what did you call
it it looked a bit like mark cery for a
second sorry this this is getting
weird oh my she very nicely put that one
back my head is getting sweaty just
thinking about
this Ru what have you done and the voice
acting as in all the last of us is
freaking incredible yeah you guys want
to see the mask I know take a picture
yeah there we go get rid of the you
should hit the x button just friends I
take it back I like to apologize to mark
C two two friends hanging out G offers
an official retraction on
her all right uh on those capes we're
going to have a little Q&A session over
here oh you going to do the thing yeah
but first triple Phoenix is that Angry
Birds yeah I think so okay but I think
they mentioned triple Phoenix once or
twice otherwise I don't know or you can
like see like a poster for it and you
can find like a poster for it in a
bedroom oh God that was not pleasant
that's scarier than any clicker I'll
tell you that much do not
like wait what's your did you oh yeah
can you still do the oh yeah you can
shake it to like uh recharge recharge
your flashlight but it made like a
little rattling noise this time look at
that skull that's new that's new in the
PS4
version all right time to talk to skeler
sker a question and shake for your
fortune
okay are we going to die
today oh that's so dark nothing oh
that's I can you make it so that she has
to wear that mask for the rest of the
game like roast stle I don't think
so what do you got seems dreadfully
unlikely seems dreadfully unlikely so
you can do this I'll do it like one more
time you can do this like 12 times I
going to get and so you can just like
during these sections you can kind of go
at your there's a little leeway in terms
of how you are paced through it it's not
just like go to this tent go to this
place where we need to move the car and
jump through a window try on three masks
and go like you can mess around trying
on masks or not we could leave here
immediately we could like ask the skele
here A bunch of crap or we could leave
here immediately there's a part later
that involves a joke book you could like
you could read like one joke or you
could read 20 jokes and there's like how
many did you read for all all of them
for sure all of them they're really
they're really good jokes idea all right
well there's no jokes in the multiplayer
this is the thing I was talking about so
this is just like let's just check this
out real quick this is a uh you you
wanted to transition I did but this is
the first
this is the first kind of like remember
that mechanic you learned in the single
player get drunk chucking bricks at at
clickers yeah kid well now you're going
to do it here and it's like you she's
going to take the blue car I'm going to
take the red car and we're going to
Chuck bricks at him and whoever smashes
the windows out first wins oh wow I I
love I love this this is like this is
like straight out of the streets of
Waterford man right here this is
straight out of the I actually have
smashed up a car with a p pole before
but let's not talk about that and then
you like run around and grab bricks and
it's like you are straight up playing
the Street Fighter 2 mini game right now
except it's way better than just mashing
buttons you got to run around and grab
bricks and like go to different areas
and it like damn look at that oh it's so
fun have they found up the only place in
this world that doesn't have clickers
everywhere yes I like it do it get it
nice Dam oh no photo mode the ban of my
existence is that just hitting the share
button yeah you know you can press uh
you can turn it on or off uh like I can
press L3 to bring it up but I can also
set it to off she has outrageous
accuracy listen well she kind of she or
Chris done is that not it oh no I think
I got to the back one the rear window
yeah crap go throw your brick at her go
yeah eat it I can't believe you just did
that I threw it over her head you want
to win don't that's just a mental Edge
come
on yes yeah you have to go get as more
bum wine yeah she spikes her she spikes
her dumb mask whatever loser I guess
that's how they force you to take off
the mask organically so it's not just
like part of it cuz she'll probably
throw it down in frustration if you lose
and then yeah and then like look you
like now you're going to like have a
your actual conversation that you've
been wanting to have with Riley and so
like the way that this left the way that
left behind like tells like tells the
story of these two characters one of
which you know but from the future and
you kind of know a little bit about her
past Ellie but then it fleshes it out a
little bit but the way that it like lets
you go at your your pace in some parts
and the way it has these moments of like
gleeful window smashing using the same
game mechanic but also like goofing
around with the masks but then asking
her like some real stuff about like the
tough questions about her own life about
their friendship like it's amazing the
way that they've scripted it and jum to
pose this stuff yeah I'm not sure if it
comes across from folks maybe on streams
when they're looking to see stuff going
crazy but anyone I know has played this
has said like you just just trust me you
gotta go play this so I think that's
probably for me anyway it's a big reason
to to go play the new PS4 version of
this SP boy th sh thank you very much
for coming on appreciate this do a fist
bump there we go that's the thing we do
although explosion going we're going to
be back in a second we're going to check
out the multiplayer on uh The Last of Us
remastered on the PlayStation 4 where
McDonald's going to join us but first of
all Assassin's Creed Unity a new trailer
came out today so let's check that b Bo
out
I can
hear the
call as I'm walking
through the
door
you a
dream in
Sun play
stre run away one
day
make
history Assassin's Creed Unity pre-order
now for two bonus offers the guillotine
spin a win game get a chance to win
prizes every Friday and the explosive
chemical Revolution Mission pre-order
now available October
28th Assassin's Creed Unity kill French
people with your friends and then a
jukebox for some reason and then a
jukebox what was that what's not to love
I didn't understand that I'm looking
forward to Unity couple months away I
think it's it's not in Far Cry 4 I don't
know you Ubisoft are doing me good this
year looking forward to it but in the
meantime real good how about we play
some The Last of Us remastered
multiplayer we're here with Ryan
McDonald what is up player dude you
played the hell out of this multiplayer
game last year I didn't play any of it
and you're one of the people who was
like this is like the best multiplayer
game that came out x's and slashes and
dots next to my name yeah all that
cryptic crap that means I played this
game a lot hell a lot more than I should
enough to where I'm embarrassed to say
how much I played that game yeah but
like the multiplayer in this game for
anyone who kind of got it's almost like
a secret part of it because the single
player was so good that people tend not
to focus on the multiplayer stuff at all
but it was genuinely like a really sort
of unique take on on like third person
multiplayer right uh yeah I mean for me
it was basically giving you kind of what
you knew and loved but but but really
you know I I mean help me out here Chris
because like part of it the
brutality um part part of it's the the
the the mixing stuff together and being
smarter than other I mean I guess that's
what it is it's triangle triangle
triangle Tri it's really good at uh at
kind of giving you a bunch of different
options to to go out there and work with
so it's not just you're you know I'm
going to run straight ahead and shoot
dudes it's like you got got be smart you
got to think about what you're going to
do you going to build Molotov and throw
it over and you know burn some dudes or
you GNA you know do like I'm doing right
now and sneak and these guys are all
bunched up like somebody com somebody
comes I mean these are my guys somebody
comes in here with a Molotov it's over
they are all dead and it's Grizzly but
so awesome yeah it's it's and it's lar
it's stuff like you can see on the mini
map you can see your allies you can see
the enemies if they Sprint or fire
non-silent weapons and can see those
little bull eyes are supply drops like
the bo that Ryan just opened so that's
where you get the crafting stuff so do
you make a bid for those knowing that
those are like map hot spots those kind
of they refresh over time and they keep
uh oh yeah you're in
trouble they keep players sort of
circulating around the map because the
more boxes you get you're getting more
stuff you're getting you know you're
getting a melee weapon like a a 2x4 that
you can then like tie a shiv to uh
Shives are you know like you can kill
someone quick if you come up behind them
and stab them but you can also gas
grenade them and then come up right in
their face and shiv is there a big down
butt not out element to this as well in
terms of you like getting hit and trying
to get away it depends on the mode
you're playing so like Supply like the
one we're playing right now it's like uh
you can see we've got 12 12 there listed
and you can see a couple x's over a
couple of our folks basically this one
is uh you know the first one to kills
you know down to the down to the zero
and then that team is done right so
there's that one but uh what was it the
uh so there's that mode then there's
survivors which is uh no respawning and
it does like round by round base yeah
and then there's a DLC they added like
late fall last year oh you got to move
who whoa who uh they added was
interrogation which is basically bad
yeah screw your friend just get out of
yeah get out the window every every
person for himself oh he's coming after
you he's coming right after you you got
a 2x4 though
oh yo I think he saw you uh
interrogation is oh wow did he get
killed yes he got so blown up instead of
doing an execution you do an
interrogation your team has to do five
of those in order to like reveal the
enemy lock box then you have to go pick
the lock box so it's a more it's the
only really objective based mode which I
really like a lot that one in the end
became my favorite yeah totally cuz
there's just a little more going on
dynamically but like I don't know like
it's it's a lot about the pace right
because the pace Ryan's going at right
now he's like he was you you can Sprint
you can walk or you can crawl like those
are the three and like they each have
visibility factors involved and of
course speed factors because you can
also do the listen mode in multiplayer
like if you press R1 Ryan's gonna
do that's R3 you can do a gesture uh
yeah you do the listen mode and he can
see like oh there's that dude is coming
right around that corner yeah take it
you're going to murder him oh
not moving at all except his other buddy
yeah who was just kind of waiting there
might have seen you onist mode but then
you've got all these perks that you can
like have longer listen mode or not be
show not show up on listen mode and the
part have a coup different levels all
that stuff is during our game though
based on XP and stuff right yes like
specifically is it class loadad stuff or
do you just unlock stuff as you you play
you yeah you I guess you get the the
custom loadouts right yeah well you
unlock yeah there are a bunch of preset
loadouts so a lot of the stuff's
available to you from the get-go but
there are custom loadouts you unlock
stuff for that in just a straight linear
fashion based on experience but then
there's also this whole other meta game
going on about your Survivor camp and
basically you've got from the menu
you've got a camp of survivors and see
this there's you can't see it on screen
right now because my face is blocking it
but you get supplies from uh every match
you play the amount of supplies you
bring back to your Camp determines how
many survivors you have so like XP so if
well dude he [__] nailed you with
that he threw it as I was throwing my
bomb and I'm pretty sure the molotov
cocked my bomb and blew it up y that was
not pretty that it's brutal the game is
brutal but like your Survivor Camp you
grow it or it shrinks and the idea is
growing it will give you little boosts
that you can activate but if it shrinks
and disappears and that everyone dies
you have to restart this sort of 12we
cycle oh wow cuz the goal is to survive
12 weeks each day each game is a day uh
and that dude's got armor he's running
um
and so there's a sort of overarching
thing which becomes really cool when you
link it with your Facebook profile
because then your then your group is
made of oh shoot that guy I'm burning
fire there's another one suck it down
get him he's coming in for the shotgun
down too oh that's all right that's all
right your teammate is there to mop it
up maybe take that devil is
Beast so it populates with your Facebook
friends and it'll be like and it pops up
little messages about what they're doing
in the camp yeah Daniel DWI is repairing
the north fence Ryan McDonald is
skinning a raccoon yes he's not skinning
that raccoon so it does the XCOM kind of
thing because then you see your homies
die you don't so good oh no water weeks
in like real world where you have to
keep playing each game is each match is
a day so it's you know 12 time 7 is 90
is 108 kind of cool so we got some
questions coming in gobu ride asks on
Twitch it's 84 go sh R Us on Twitch how
many Maps will be available on
multiplayer do you know have small Park
like what are we talking five or 10 12
okay yeah decent amount then 12 I'm
going to guess cuz I think prob maybe
even more maybe 16 cuz I I know each of
the map packs had uh trouble yeah you're
in trouble he's going to throw a
firebomb at you in your
bone get him how can I not shoot that
man in the
face oh there's three of them yeah you
HT
oh no were you trying to shoot around
him so right yeah you just that much of
a pacifist it's all over though look at
that zero zero H scrb asks do you find a
PS4 controller makes for better gameplay
better shooting smoother action have you
f any difference between that and the
PS3 controller I will say is that why
you miss just there I will say the
smoother I I will say the smoother I
think uh cuz that was the first question
I asked you is like did it seem faster
that was that was my problem with Last
of Us and where I ended my last of last
love affair was Titanfall came out and
so I started playing Titanfall and uh
and somehow the speed difference between
running around on walls and then going
back to this I just couldn't do it and
so uh it's a big change yeah it's super
super different so yeah so that I will
say that I am uh I'm happy to see that
the smoother definitely seems to kind of
I'm into it yeah yeah I want to keep
playing are you going to go back and
play it I'm going to download it tonight
yeah yeah yeah I was waiting to see what
you guys were going to say and now that
we are here yes I will play this game
what about yourself of course I'm going
to wear a different
hat straw cowboy hat yeah that's
inconspicuous that's you're inating look
I'll just put on a surgeon mask they'll
never know who I am just say shout medic
whenever you run out there and they
they'll
stop uh will I play I would I would get
in a few match of the matches of this
for sure I mean it's that here let's try
to also get the bow burst right like
there's a bunch of different ways to
play like tactically I'm I'm G to show
I'm gon to go burst rifle make some rain
that's what they call me down to my
local bar so I've also so you can see
you get a quick glimp rain maker is that
okay spittle yeah is that weird I guess
no uh so you can see here like there's
the Survivor Camp I've got 32 survivors
look at them all they're in a fence
they're a little tree dish uh they're
healthy if I came back with so I need 31
supplies per match if I come back with
less they get hungry they get sick and
then they die right uh but it's not
telling me if anyone one is doing any
cool Matt Brady empty ethanol still
who's Matt Brady in your life he's a
dude I went to high school with great
he's a sports cter on radio now he knows
how to empty an ethanol listen man in
the you know in this kind of world you
got to do what you got to do can you can
you why who what else are people doing
uh so I can't I can't choose to switch
and see more things it'll just
automatically cycle it's updating me on
my like current challenge so they'll
give you these contextual challenges
they'll be like we've discovered a
massing group Hunters nearby massing for
an attack in 3 days we need to train up
and uh otherwise we could suffer heavy
losses so then you choose a goal so you
like Downs executions heals kills with a
certain weapon and then there are a
couple tiers I get it they like they
kind of dressed up the XP progression to
this like yeah well that and that's sort
of like the XP progression in this is
just a very rote uh yo Kelly Garrison
Goomer is digging a new latrine yeah she
is you know she's going to take a dump
in that dig hole how come it doesn't
load her picture why does this thing uh
my Facebook connection like it doesn't
load my Facebook profile picture which
is what it's using as my PSN thing
there's a little bit of a it's it's
actually really sad the one thing I'll
say is really sad trying buddy this game
just came out today so oh man optimal
games are not like abounding like the
one thing that's super sad is like you
know a lot of people use their Facebook
pictures uh instead of them it's like
you know they little kid or something
it's a so it's just this terrible
message comes across about something
that happened to them and then just
pictures a little smiling kid yeah so
like your nieces and nephews are like
digging latr holes
and if they're hasn't eaten in 48 hours
like is K can't stop thinking about food
yo Jenny Nelson's grilling a rat yeah
Jen straight up grilling a rat she would
totally do that she is awesome she's
going to be my sister-in-law is she yeah
I hope she got grilled rat at the
wedding they'd better have it although
you know no one grills it quite like she
does it would be a pale in in you know
imitation so so check this out see the
the lineup of people and the numbers
next to them my question is so if I buy
the remastered version and I get into
this does my no really no way man what
do you think I'm 02 slashers I'm just
checking just checking I'm more than 02
I'm like a 123 slash or whatever so yeah
the number the number is actually how
many of these challenges you've
completed so it's basically how many
weeks because there's a challenge per
week and then the slashes are how many
uh 12we periods they'll change but it's
not just like it'll stack flashes
they'll be like sideways slashes and
Weir dots and it's totally inscrutable
yeah so when you were looking for this
map were you just looking for any
available game I CH I went into the uh
Supply raid okay so just in case cuz
some folks might be wondering if if
every single time they you know does it
take this long to get into a match I
mean it's day one the even the load time
on the other one was a while on the PS3
yeah it's not like super brisk uh but
like you this is the same freaking map I
voted for something else sorry folks uh
but M off even with
um it is a little faster like the match
we got into that Ryan played did not
take as long as this one took just
before because we did it in the
transition but it's still it was faster
and it's day one I mean if you buy this
day one odds are you're going to be
playing the campaign I don't know all
right we got some jibber jabber I got
some questions while you guys are while
this is loading in uh do remaster
multiplayer people play with PS3
multiplayer people asks on Twitch no I
don't think so it's a straight up I'm
pretty sure it's it's separate
because because like the the remastered
crowd has all the DLC maps but the PS3
crowd might not and the PS3 crowd has
all sorts of crazy slashes and stuff and
you know if they're going to start
bringing that stuff over PS4 which the
DLC maps they are all in already right
from the GetGo oh right sorry focusing
one might not um base pilot asks
graphical Fidelity being boosted on the
multiplayer as well as single player do
you seen much of a difference
it's definitely moves smoother uh and
and a little it looks a little sharper
oh yeah just get dude every time I pick
up that's explosive powder it just looks
like a marijuana leaf yeah I'm like yeah
give me the weed I'm GNA blow someone up
I'm going to blow up my brain it's not
weed it's not no it's explosive bits
life in the funnies on Twitch asks how
much is this you guys what this is 59.95
yeah it's like PlayStation 4 game price
what about digital
I don't know actually I'm going to look
it up is there any like Digi bonuses I
was I was planning to spend 60
bucks try to go up here and see if I
can't blast down on some fools 50 49
50 $50 $49.99 you can take that sent
home oh hello right inead shoot that
lady with the bow shootter shoot her
punch her punch that lady oh no they're
shooting me yeah take the interrogation
no did I get it this game this game is
messed up did I get oh no I didn't have
to interrogate I thought I was playing
interrogation I would have I would not
have gone for the execution there you
got you got you got plus 10 I got the
kill that was pretty gnarly I got the
kill but so if it's interrogation mode I
have to get down and do the execution
animation because otherwise I won't get
the interrogation point you need like
four of those right to be able five that
was pretty brutal it is brutal dude and
and it shows you that same view if
that's happening to you like like you
totally just watch your character model
get worked and it's really gnarly you
got nothing to burn him with I have
nothing man I don't I ain't got no
supplies you don't know you're there all
you can see is a cowboy hat sticking out
of the window oh who did that that guy
yeah that guy yeah here we go oh yep oh
just watch it happen just watch it
fraking happen it's gnarly and then
they've got the
uh so you can like upgrade your weapons
and buy more ammo and
a purchasable weon or armor but this is
all in the specific match not outside
the match do you tend to do that a l
yeah definitely buy armor I also really
like to do the weapon upgrades I will
some I will often not buy not equip a uh
purchasable weapon cuz even though
they're more powerful like just
upgrading your normal
weapon can be a really good move you
know it's like for me it was as simple
as first thing you get is that armor
right and then once you get that armor
it's upgrading your your
weapon I guess you can go you know kind
on what feeling like want more Firepower
more but for me it was always the armor
and then the weapon and it was like that
last third of the match I'd usually just
be rocking
people yeah cuz that if you upgrade the
weapon it's
really I love the look of the
molotov it's just so
nasty there you go there you go shoot
that junk yeah you got him you got him
it's hard with the at from this distance
that oh yeah oh yeah pure movement big
84 what are these oh these guys okay you
guys cool up there all right you're fine
I'm going to try to grab some are they
making bum wine upstairs yeah well I
mean you know you got to stay stay
frosty with some warm bum wine all I
want you get one more kill and then
we're going to peace out on the Last of
Us remastered until they make another HD
version next year let me just go in my
truck and uh do some you can do it Chris
can I craft kill or be killed I'm just
going to nail bomb the crap out of
everybody do it oh really bad spot I
went to like the one exposed spot in the
truck to craft not
smooth okay here we go I don't want to
be detected kill or be killed you look
like a cowboy and a cowboy there are
more Shadows than was oh maybe no yeah
that dude trouble
trouble oh big oh shoot in your face oh
he shot it before it hit him oh what a
jerk and he's going oh my limbs did you
see that Mo 117 oh that was that was
great have it pry son of a oh my God The
Last of Us remastered available today on
the PlayStation 4 or you can just buy
the PS3 one if you want as well who
knows whatever you want H that's awesome
I'm looking forward to playing some more
of this uh bad boy when I get back dude
Left Behind is the business and also the
multiplayer is the business furthermore
the single player campaign is it the
business yeah great all right you know
what else is the business comicone it's
just over these two jokers ratted I
wasn't so I'm going to use the lobby to
basically find out what the goddamn hell
was going on cuz I didn't go to e3.
gamespot.com and or ComiCon that's what
that's the problem I was on E3 page the
whole time Chris is going to kill
somebody is he go back go back go back
go back oh what he jumped up on the
ledge you tricky bastard that's amazing
whatever love it I deserve that it's all
right for the rest of the show we'll
just cut back every time Chris looks
like he's going to kill someone it's
going to happen ComiCon stuff coming up
we got Dragon Age Inquisition trailer
right now so check it out
welcome to Dragon Age Inquisition this
is the first in a series of videos
showcasing the gameplay features of
bioware's latest
RPG this segment details the game's
flexible multifaceted combat
systems player choice dictates combat in
Dragon Age Inquisition every encounter
can be approached in a multitude of ways
using a combination of real-time action
and the pause andplay tactical
camera players seeking a more action
oriented approach can lead from the
front where the gracefully wielding
daggers staggering a foe with a
Warhammer or unleashing devastating
spells The Inquisitor will be supported
in combat by a party of unique and
Amazing Allies from the mighty iron bull
to the powerful Mage viven each brings a
specialized mix of abilities and
weaponry to the
battlefield you can customize your party
in advance by setting preference for a
specific ability or for a more measured
strategic approach to combat the player
can issue commands in the heat of battle
using the Tactical
camera this feature removes time from
the equation allowing you to get more
information about the enemies you're
facing in order to tailor your
attack each party member can be selected
and given a variety of commands from
attacking specific targets moving to a
point defending an
area Reviving a Down Party member or
using potions poisons or
Elixir commands are clearly reflected on
the screen and communicate each
follower's objective after issuing
orders the player can restart time
starting and stopping at any point to
adjust their approach or see how their
tactics are played
out for example in this maneuver the
player is strategically blocking off the
enemies in order to divide and
conquer the C camer can be adjusted for
a big picture view or pulled in
tight taking the element of choice even
further the player can explore or enter
battle play against any one of the
followers that make up their party
battles in real time become pulse
pounding Affairs where every attack and
maneuver can spell the difference
between Victory or defeat one thing that
remains consistent is the challenging
aspect of combat Dragon Age
Inquisition each encounter from swarms
of demons to towering High dragons will
take the full force of The Inquisitor
and party to
overcome nobody expects the Dragon Age
Inquisition I wasn't a ComicCon last
week but everyone else sitting on this
couch was Chris Waters who's going to
continue to play The Last of Us
multiplayer I stop any time Peter Brown
as well you keep playing you having fun
over there Ry Ma has split into two
people and those two people are Peter
Brad and Justin hayal who have gone to
ComiCon I had a really funny story at
Comic Con I'm going to say really quick
so I was standing in line for that that
Court the Assassin's Creed Ubisoft they
had a parkour course going and I was I
was taking some pictures I was getting
ready to run it myself and a kid comes
up to me he goes are you Peter Brown
from Gamespot I love your work no oh
that's the best yeah I said no and I I
said I'm ugly Peter Brown did somebody
come up to you and say are you Justin
nope oh that's heartbreaking oh that's
white people oh my God beards we do look
kind of similar pretty great and we wear
the same t-shirt sometimes he has I
almost wore that t-shirt that's why you
wear a hoodie today you away it Comic
Con was awesome it was you were going to
go anyway like you were going you were
going to take time off and just go and
then it's like you can pay me for that
if you if you don't pay me I'm not going
to work but I'm going to go anyway cuz I
really love the movies and the TV shows
and there's a little bit of games and
comics but it it is a show about really
awesome movies and and I love walking
the ComiCon show floor and the huge set
pieces they put together it's like it's
like E3 but in a very different way it's
like we got to walk by the WETA Workshop
where they had a a giant smug head and
like I love seeing that getting to see
new movie trailers as they come out I
got to watch TR uh the Gotham and the
Flash they did the pilots for those
shows like for me that's a lot of fun
and you get a lot more of that at
Comic-Con than you do at any other show
really did you go to some of the panels
H yeah we went to we had to go to a lot
of video game panels because we're
covering that and we had to go we had oh
it's so hard doing my job but the the
Skylanders panel was great of which you
know I'm not a big Skylanders fan but
they had the guy doing one of the voices
I guess a voice in Skylanders is a guy
who's in Invader Zim like he would just
interject throughout the entire panel
you always had these voice actors at a
lot of these panels who would interject
and they would play their character and
it you know makes it really funny it's
it's nice to listen to I went to a
Sesame Street panel moderated by Chris
hard had Cookie Monster and Grover and
of course they just did the panel as
Cookie Monster and Grover it was
absolutely hilarious that's great what
about yourself Peter you saw a couple of
video game on yeah yeah I think the the
two that were the most fun were the
street fighter and Tekken related panels
uh the Tekken one was particularly great
because if you know katsuhiro Hara the
director of Tekken and the creator of
the whole series he's got a really good
sense of humor he's one of those kind of
like in-your-face personalities where a
lot of Japanese devs tend to be very
reserved and on point and on the big
projector on the screen he had uh faces
for shono the guy behind Street Fighter
currently and uh Tomo noo idaki the
creator of dead or alive and had like
red crosses over their faces like banned
from panel like cannot enter uh but yeah
there they confirmed that Tekken Cross
Street Fighter is still in development
and that's something you're kidding me
nope and I've been arguing with people
around this office about that for weeks
a long time don't we just assume it was
cancelled and you like to troll me a lot
it's really fun yes but yeah now that
game is still in development apparently
uh still development or now in
development still in development but
it's been like two years since they
announced that right I want to say four
I think it's been wow you kidding me
yeah no that was the Street Fighter
cross Tekken they announced those at the
same time yeah yeah yeah was that four
years ago yeah and the whole stick that
he was saying is like the game is still
in development we're just not showing it
because every product needs the right
time to be showcased so stop worrying
we're making the game we're just not
showing it off yet right so they've also
got a new Tekken coming out as well
though right Tekken seven yeah and it's
supposed to be the conclusion to the
Tekken Saga right the thing bet it won't
be the last game maybe not the last
Tekken game but but there's but they're
seriously tying together like the main
story line that's sort of been there so
far so maybe they'll start a new story
line or something but they will call it
Tekken 8 they will probably call it
Tekken or Tekken they will pull software
and just go straight up we're going back
to
1991 I could do a final fantasy do a
Tekken 72 Tekken X 7 7x Chris Waters was
also at ComiCon he was locked in a room
like this one the entire time yeah did
you get to see anything I got to go to
the show floor on preview night and the
show floor for me is you know seeing the
smog is like really cool it's like its
mouth was moving its eyeball was kind of
looking at you but for me Comic Con is
all about like the cool artists that you
can find there so like a little bit away
from the big TV and movie booths you
know you go in One Direction you can
sort of get to artists alley where it's
just the actual artist is there like
drawing stuff taking requests like
autographing but then you go other
direction and you get through like all
these rows that just are like people
have their graphic novel their plushies
their t-shirt their buttons like all
sort of around their whatever crazy idea
they came up with and it's really
freaking cool uh just to see the like
the breadth of creativity on offer and
actually I saw someone who we recognized
from the lobby Danny oh really Jill who
brought in the Twitch Plays robot oh
yeah she's an illustrator as well oh
cool so she had a booth I bought a whale
Kano t-shirt from her that folks who
watch the
uh show could spot and uh yeah that's
for to me that's what is so exciting
about ComiCon I was bummed out I was
seeing all you guys posting photographs
and stuff sitting at home here in San
Francisco one of Chris's big goals is
always to collect t-shirts you were
telling me did you pick up any other hot
t-shirts I got three uh they were all
displayed on the each day of the live
show uh that's exclusive for to San
Diego ComiCon live show currently does
that mean you expense them Chris it's
wardrobe expenses Danny I mean I these
t-shirts don't grow on trees so you
know this was actually a last year's
ComiCon haul this uh Studio gibli lineup
but you can see the new t-shirts on the
show in the coming months I just want to
give it you know it's a timed exclusive
for San Diego Comic-Con live streams how
big is your T-shirt
collection how many t-shirts do you have
you wore them all at one side before I
went to not possible before I went to
Comic Con I laid them all out I took an
Instagram of them and I counted them and
it was like 80 it was wow of I own like
people who watch this show will be
[__] well aware I own about
four I'm going back to Ireland where I
left maybe two more so check those out
in a couple of weeks Danny's wardrobe
increases by 50% what was your favorite
thing about Comic Con this year Well I
wouldn't say my my favorite thing but I
think one of the most interesting that's
the question I asked but thanks very
much for totally observing it the the
most interesting thing at ComicCon are
the lines like how absolutely ridiculous
they are so we did a segment which I
don't know if it's actually ever going
to go live but Peter and I walked the
entire so there's a Hall h to to set
this up H is a separate Hall from the
rest of the I me it's onto the the panel
the building fits like 8,000 people or
something and this is where they do the
big movie panels the big TV show
premieres and if you want to get into
this hole there's a separate line
there's a line that's called for
everything except Hall h and there's a
line for Hall h right and on Saturday
Saturday morning people were lined up no
Friday morning people are lined up from
like 4:00 a.m. to get into this Hall the
next day for sat aturday night and we
walked we started about 10:30 p.m. and
we walked until 11:15 p.m. what for
that's how long it took us to walk from
one into the other God and it's not just
a straight line too cuz this line like
doubles around itself they kind of like
you know Loop it at a point so it
doesn't go as long as it could Terri
doesn't go to Mexico which it probably
would it felt like getting back to San
Francisco as we were interviewed like we
did a couple interviews talked to a
couple people in the lines and as we
were talking to the final person in just
like the span of two minutes 10 more
people had showed up at the end of the
line my God like it it was it's so
interesting and weird there were a
couple people here in the office who was
like hey Justin can you can you pick me
up this really cool piece of Swag I'm
like sure I'll try for for the last day
there's a Lego thing that somebody asked
me to pick up yeah if you wanted to get
there I had a friend who showed up an
hour before the show doors opened I
showed up as the doors were opening on
Sunday the final day you had to go to
the Lego Booth to get a ticket to come
back just to just for the chance of
buying something and neither of us
that's I couldn't deal with that I could
not deal with that I want to go on
Amazon and spend four times as much for
all the people who got the tickets and
bought them when they were actually at
ComiCon that's the only way to get some
of this craziness outside of ComicCon uh
there are some like legit news that has
dropped today as well right EA are doing
some crazy Netflix action on the Xbox
one yeah it's they just announced today
kind of a surprise announcement where if
you want access to Electronic Arts games
they're doing something called EA access
access and for $5 a month or for $30 a
year they're going to give you a
ostensibly access to your entire EA
catalog to the back catalog at least is
is how they're pitching it right now you
have access to four titles it's only in
beta so it's not open to everybody guess
the four titles the four go ahead guess
it FIFA yes Madden yes
uh Battlefield yes and one more and is
it UFC or something dumb it is not what
is it it's pigle two pegle two all right
I don't feel too bad about not getting
that one so right now you can pay I
think that that's a pretty good deal
like if you were going to buy it it
seems like it pays for itself I mean for
30 bucks a year you get access to the
the entire catalog of of old EA games
they haven't said how this is going to
work for new games coming up though so
like you know you're going to be excited
for Hardline and Dragon Age Inquisition
how long is it going to take you to get
access to those once you're out like
that's the the big question there's also
going to be uh is it less I heard maybe
DLC is going to cost less if you're on
this program yeah so you have a 10%
discount if you want to get access to
the DLC maps and that kind of content
another interesting thing that so we did
a Q&A uh and this is going to go up
shortly once you download these games
even if you get rid of the service it's
you have access to it forever it's only
on Xbox One to be clear this is not a a
PC service only on Xbox one but once you
download that game you have access to it
forever okay so that's cool right so so
it's 30 bucks a year and I've bought
Battlefield pegle 2 FIFA and Madden
that's probably good if you're going to
buy the DLC even at a 10% discount and
then it it basically isn't yours
afterwards if on the subscription uh so
what's stopping me from from signing up
for a month downloading 20 games and
then pcing out on on EA Sports access
I'm guessing the yeah access it's going
to be that they have a good library of
stuff that you want to keep accessing
like that's really got to be the only
real hook for this um as somebody plays
FIFA and gets it every single year and
is left with like eight copies of FIFA
from the past eight years that I will
never go back and play at least that
that seems like a good enough reason I'm
sure people who play Madden have the
same but the problem is that if you want
to play that FIFA as soon as it comes
out you're still going to have to drop
60 bucks just for the to experience FIFA
as it comes out I I assume if you want
to wait like maybe three four I think
it's going to be like the Netflix model
where you do get access to new movies
but after like three months or four
months or whatever all right Justin
hawal Peter brownan thanks very much
coming on no thanks for having us at
Comic Con and stuff Have you had enough
rest it's like five days of work you CH
that yet yeah I'm feel all right I came
back Saturday night so yeah I'm right I
came back Sunday night about 11:00 p.m.
and I was like I'm just going to come in
to work on Monday and I worked really
hard and I was like like I'm going to go
home and maybe you know catch up on some
TV or reading and I passed out from 700
p.m. until 7: a.m. this morning all
right well you know halfway through the
week you're almost there thanks very
much coming in thanks for having us and
doing all that ComiCon business we're
going to be back in a couple of minutes
Firefall is out oh my God Kevin Van's
going to come on the show and I talk to
us about that in a second but first of
all here's a montage of some of the
wonderful sites of
ComicCon
he
pap
what's up folks welcome back hey did you
know the Firefall the video game which
was premiered I feel like five or six
four or five years ago at this stage no
not that long ago it's been that long
really this is a game made by I believe
a bunch of EX blizard dudes uh I think
there's maybe not all of them are
involved in it at this stage still but
it's been a long time coming it's like
first person shooter mixed with MMO
action you've been playing for past
couple of days right yeah I I mean in
theory I've been trying to play for the
last week but it sometimes comes and
goes you know like when you have a job
and stuff sometimes you have to stop
isn't your job to play Firefall it it is
now yes actually and also to wear
Firefall t-shirts apparently God you're
wearing shirt this is actually a funny
coincidence by the way uh because we
just got this yesterday and I'm Al
almost out of clean clothes right so I
thought I'll just wear this shirt today
and then I like oh but I'm now I'm going
to show Firefall on the show today it's
perfect so I'm I I mean it could only
have been better if I would have say
like drank Mountain Dew and if you we
red hat and its developer is red five
Studios no oh yep C me
when we give it a 10.0 in gamot you'll
know why I'm only wearing this cuz it
because it's red my favorite color and
there's an adorable bear suit on it so
your first take Fire Fall has has a
plane it's fine I guess like I'm I'm
still so early on but I got to say thank
you Chris Waters welome and maybe we can
get a mouse pad in here for not now but
for the next time fre Madonna I know
right you want to use this paper so give
us thisby people never heard of Fire
Fall so fire fall is it really is oh God
they brought me a mouse pad that's so
sweet everybody's so good to me service
with a smile take away this isn't good
enough for me you're
doing jet I I keep pushing the the the
table down I'm going to I'm going to try
to to stop doing that a light touch ven
ORD yeah all right nice JP pack Firefall
for the folks who don't know what it is
let's try that again so Firefall really
is an MMO shooter in in the most classic
possible sense that you could imagine it
like destiny
no but seriously more like Defiance okay
or something like that is there third
person as well um there is third person
I can switch right out you see me
looking pretty buff aren't I
beautiful I've been working hard nice
ponytail so it has a very I'll show you
the map where I am right now um it has a
very typical MMO kind of feel to it
you've got the map and I'm going out and
I have to take missions and I can take
stuff from the job board and of course
it's all it's all sci-fi but it's it's
real time shooting in the sense that it
is a real shooter and this is a
persistent shared World among you and
and uh all of the other people like this
person that is playing what you're doing
look real person hey real person real
person Aries how big is the world in
comparison is is this a Azeroth type
everything's connected or is this instan
like uh Star Wars older well there are
instances um but it is but you do have
of course the giant Overworld um that
I'm going through now and most of the
stuff that I'm doing takes place there
unless it's a story instance and and for
the most part stuff I'm doing is
is right out there so I'll go ahead and
take a take a
job and Sergeant Lewis is going to tell
me where to go next are the jobs very
much in the MMO vein of kill 10 of this
bring this to this person yes okay is
that okay or are you finding a TR I mean
I think it's okay I mean sometimes it
comes across as TR one of the reasons
for that is uh I'm going to see if I can
set up my oh no I'm playing on a
different PC so all my all my presets
are are wrong oh I was going to set up
my glider can you give me a second so
set my glider show us some this GL set
up my glider um so yeah I've got uh
crafting components consumable items but
I have uh where is it here here's
energized
after that kind of looks like a
glider yeah is it the one that looks
like a little
V Boomerang shot
nope you lie you don't even own a glider
I do own a glider I swear where but
anyway let's not worry about the glider
for now is it a reusable
item I guess oh yeah was I on the wrong
side yeah it is a reusable item here we
go Vehicles pets
Deployable
Thum here's the glider
pad and we'll get my vehicle in there
there's not much in terms of sorry about
that put a pet out there yeah put a pet
there oh you want me to put a pet out
there okay little claw or baby red panda
panda yeah that's Jesus why' you there's
only one answer vanard
all right so I summoned my
panda I don't see a panda but I don't
see a
panda maybe I have to set it down
somewhere did you see it no I just saw a
little thing running in the distance so
maybe I don't know there he
is there he is red
panda a yeah that's not going to do much
it looks kind of cute but also kind of
terrifying all right so let's uh take
the speeder instead oh sweet you can
just spawn a card it's his
Destiny whoa look at that thing look at
that big wheel is there much Variety in
the vehicles and stuff do you have to
buy this or is this a I actually bought
this with uh with some real money oh we
should we should mention right now in
case you did not notice this is a freeo
playay video game yeah this is a
free-to-play game um just also
subscription if you want correct there's
like a what it does is if you get one of
those packs it's basically one of those
things where you get a certain amount of
money and you get you get bonuses for
for buying stuff yeah um that would be
cheaper than if you just bought it all
outright right so uh we it looks like a
jump to me too Kevin H how much would
that cost if you didn't pay real money
oh you know what I don't know I don't
know that's a very good
question all right thank Ryan ma for it
what is that thing so I dropped a turret
heo go close to it go close to that
thing and these
are a large portion of the enemies St
super
bugs I kind of really like the art style
actually yeah it's it's uh you know it
has some of that Borderlands vibe that
people like although I think that you
know you sell it short if you just say
oh it's colorful and kind of sell shaded
so it must be like Borderlands but it
does have some of that appeal um and of
course uh with with all of the uh
weapons that I've gotten so far I've
inspected the corpse and I'm playing as
an engineer now you you get these things
called battleframes and that's your
class like you're not stuck in any one
style you can get whatever battle frames
you want it's like a suit you sit you're
in right yeah it really is and so
everything that you do is based on so
there I think
um that there
are six basic types of battleframes and
they all have uh
additional variants so for example I'm
an engineer but you can uh you're not
you know there there other types of
engineers um that you can play as with
different Specialties but so far um but
but they all level up separately so
right now I've just been sort of
sticking to um my
engineer
we'll go ahead and uh is there any any
cool down on that thing or there is a
little bit but it's not long
um driving across the ocean driving
across the ocean if you have any
questions for Kevin by the way for
Firefall uh by all means in the twitch
chat or Gamespot comments and I may not
know the answer because I've only I'm
only level nine so I feel like uh oh I I
bet you that this only counts as like uh
10 hours of play or something like that
so I'll just get out there we'll jet
pack up see what else is going on this
available only on PC at the moment it is
only PC and I suspect it will only ever
be PC okay um but one thing that I like
about this too oh I'm sorry is that I
can as an engineer then I can repair
like my turrets like so for example with
the same gun that you're zapping the
dudes with it's just the secondary fire
so that's that's kind of cool and I have
another gun like under tournament
nonsense I like it yeah and I was going
to say I mean there there are quite a
few free to-play
Shooters you know with on connectivity
on the PlayStation 4 yeah yeah blackl
retribution Planet Side Y plan side is
coming yeah
coming yeah so who knows possi in the
future yeah it's interesting though
because this is I I would say that you
know it's easy to look at stuff like
people and we we've talked about this in
the office before too and i' I've
managed to tee off people on Twitter for
that matter saying you know I wouldn't
classify Destiny as an MMO yeah what
what is the difference between this and
what is well to to me the the very
defining um thing about an MMO is that
uh oops I ran out of ran out of energy
bullets uh yep so I'm going to wait for
there we go just build like an ammo pad
yeah as an engineer I got an ammo pad it
also has a health thing on it too but I
used that
up but uh I I think having a persistent
world that is persistent regardless of
your presence in it is uh one of the
most defining fact is the defining
factor of an MMO um I don't think that
uh I think that something like Destiny
is is all essentially instanced and
people come and go based on uh based on
your your point in the story or or or
other things like that so but to me this
is a this is a an always persistent
World um that is not split up like that
like I am out here you wouldn't know it
but I am out here actually sharing this
space with lots of other people although
at this stage there's nothing that seems
particularly massive about the the
number of people playing right now can
you I kind of alluded to it earlier can
you Traverse like the entire map like
world Warcraft style or is they say you
go from one planet to another or a
different side of the planet or believe
I believe that there are uh transitions
where you go from Zone to Zone but I
haven't even like at this stage I
haven't even gotten to that point yet
that is one funky ass glider yeah I feel
that this is the first time I'm playing
on this PC so I feel kind of bad like
the tutorials come up and kind of get in
the way of it this is my super duper
rainbow glider that's pretty great
that's pretty pretty cool is there day
night cycles happening here as well
there is day night cycle
absolutely uh life in the funnies on
Twitch is asking is there PVP there is
PVP I haven't done it yet but there are
PVP zones zones are is there any PVP in
the in the there I there are uh like uh
duels okay and things like that as well
so uh there's also something that I'm
looking forward to and I haven't done
yet they're also um large raids 40 Man
raids um and I I haven't done it but I
have seen it in action and it it looks
pretty cool pretty dramatic oh I've seen
a couple of like yeah like end bosses
that have been pretty big impressive
looking it looks pretty impressive so at
this stage it's interesting because you
know I've played you know how many
zillion MMOs in my life so three zillion
three zillion yes you're right three
zillion so I I will say that I I think I
was expecting going into this sort of uh
you know kind of an MMO with the added
charge of excitement coming from just
being a shooter yeah I have to say I
come bored most of the time yeah I mean
a lot of it just seems to be going
through the motions and the
enemies you've been killing these things
kind of predominantly really strange AI
in a lot of cases I just dropped the
shield there which is something that an
engineer can do are you playing have you
been playing with other folks I have
played with other folks um I'm kind of
surprised there aren't more uh people a
lot of the time when I'm playing
although I have I do have some friends
playing with me and occasionally I get
together with strangers and do stuff um
but none of that's felt particularly
necessary there are you know group
necessary things here another thing I'm
going to do now is maybe I'll uh put
down a thumper um Thumpers are mining
machines and if you want a lot of
resources yeah um for crafting and
upgrades and stuff um you can set down a
thumper do they scare away those ant
things because then contrary Danny they
do the opposite really so it's like the
anti halflife 2 level before Nova
Prospect yep but I got to put uh I
forgot yo you should spawn a panda
again get your panda friend to help you
out yeah yeah make a panda thump things
thump your Panda yeah look at him can
you can you just like Crouch and have a
look at his cute adorable face this a
pretty nasty looking face look at him
he's pretty mean yeah he looks pretty
mean that's like a more of a wolverine
Panda or something that's like if they
went underwent like reverse
domestication that like made them look
fiercer and more wild it's like musly
like those weird cows those Belgian
blues that are like look super muscle
cows terrifying definitely super muscle
cow I would not leave that with a
toddler unaccompanied oh look at this so
is this used to farm those Farm those
things or is your pet even doing does
your petet just a cosmetic pet that
doesn't actually kind of hangs out and
looks nasty then why does it look nasty
if it doesn't have to attack it should
be cuddly it should be cute as hell m
asks on Twitch what sets this game apart
from all other MMO
Shooters well when I think of MMO
Shooters the the thing that the things
that come up or Planet you know Planet
Side 2 is the easy is the easy thing to
come up um and in that sense Planet Side
2 is all PVP very PVP Focus that's all
it is um where this is PVE focused um
the you know what about global agenda
Kevin I never played Global agenda but I
believe that that had instanced um for
the most part that was instanced right
yes there was only a PVP arena in that
one but it was mostly running raids on
so Defiance is is very easily the the
easiest game to compare this to um and I
got to say Defiance was weird I got some
somebody that decided to get it on the
AC left just take a take a pot shot on
her way through yeah defines so yeah I'm
sorry I'm I'm really bad at playing and
talking at the same time this is why I'm
never on the show don't sell yourself
short banard you're doing great but
defance Defiance had a very different
atmosphere but Defiance did a much
better job of bringing people together
the arkfalls in defiance were really
cool um you always had a reason go out
they were public events um and you know
this this has some of that too the one
of the big things about this game is
that you know you can replay missions
and go through the same areas but you
know it's not like in most MMOs where
the same creatures all spawn in the same
exact places and in the same exact way
and so on and after the same amount of
time this is this is a little bit more
dynamic in terms of how things
spawn um but in terms of defiance with
that I always felt like I was always out
you know in the world doing different
stuff I always felt like um certain
levels were were set up in clever ways
to make it feel um more like a shooter
than an MMO in which you shot which I
think was really interesting um so I
would say overall I had a better time
with uh with Defiance than I have had
with this game revie this at the moment
I am reviewing this at the moment when
we have a review onam who knows um I'd
like to probably you know I I want to
make sure I get to at least max level
with one with one battlef frame which is
what 50 60 um not sure okay yeah I like
I said like I'm I'm the the worst person
to ask questions because I I really now
just getting into it yeah um and most of
my time has been spent doing stuff like
this either alone or with others are you
able to exit the game at any stage now
because the best part of ending a show
when you're doing a MMO Mo last is it
totally just destroys the character
situation of the person playing oh yeah
no no thisit Escape what
happens you're B you're
bone thanks that's helpful yeah there's
no pausing in MMOs oh look that big
thing oh it's a big one there's no
crying in baseball there's no pausing in
MMOs there are just certain things that
don't happen Okay well you keep playing
that while we wrap off the show all
right o can I help wrap up even while I
play no godam you just Bey yourself your
Firefall t-shirt but are getting
exciting God damn it uh that's the show
for today uh before we leave I want to
let you guys in on a competition uh from
our good friends at Sony are doing do do
you remember outside E3 there was that
big mural yeah in the place where they
normally park like a giant tank there
was just they were painting this mural
with like all these PlayStation
characters like you know the guy from
resistance and a Kill Zone and
Assassin's Creed and like a basketball
player from NBA or something that is
that Washington Crossing the Delaware is
that what that's called that is that
image I'm not but yeah that was outside
the South Hall all week and this was the
finished product was which left a blank
and they filled in that blank they did
dude called Joey Chu he was the uh he
was the first guy in line to get the
PlayStation oh that dude yeah yeah
remember Jeff balar inter yeah when we
were doing those live streams those
launch live streams he interviewed him
so that guy B that guy's the greatest
yeah so they filled him in on that bad
boy so nice work Buddy son you're doing
a basically sort of a copy of that
competition on online uh you may have
seen greatness of.com uh flashed out
around the place they're basically doing
some sort of web app where you can make
your own version of a mural I don't know
exactly what that entails but I think it
involves putting your face and your dude
in with a load of other like Sony video
game characters yeah the site's not up
just yet but like you G I guess you're
going to be able to choose from a bunch
of Sony so like yeah I'm totally putting
like Jody Holmes yeah who would be on
your monkey and trip from uh enslaved
would just be me and transistor lady red
red yeah yeah yeah not sure if that
counts I get some master onion in there
probably oh my God Master onion mhm FIB
ribbon maybe someday so you're going to
be able to like do this thing on
greatness aes.com and the idea is like
great you're a greatest moments or
Channel your favorite greatest
characters and you're going to get to
like make the mural and answerer chance
to win like yourself painted in a mural
so PlayStation 4 and then a copy of oh
yeah and a PlayStation 4 freaking
PlayStation 4 and and a copy ofur so
yeah if you go to greatness.com you
should be able to do that later the week
Chris Waters I'm going away I'm going on
holidays to Ireland for a couple weeks
yeah I want to give you a homework
assignment can you make a mural homework
assignment make a mural yeah I'm going
to make a mural if you get onion from
PaRappa the Raper in there I think that
Sony should just give you the
PlayStation there uh yeah well I'm gonna
try my darnest yeah I'll do it and then
since you're away I'm hosting next week
going to be in the sweaty chair do you
know what's going to be on next week no
apart from you showing off your amazing
onion mural it's going to be my amazing
onion mural okay I might even bring in
real onions to help uh you guys get seen
into the process more authentic how much
we we we plan these shows put some
googly eyes on it my God it's going to
be great I want to say a very special
thanks to Mary Kish who's been running
the jib today and I want everyone who's
watching the exit of the show to be
super critical about how good the
exiting Chip Shot is we in dog work off
at ComiCon as as did Mary and everyone
else in the the the live Live Crew back
but I just want you guys to know that
this jip shot is it's super important to
you're the best super important to you
can do it so if we all if we all hold
hands we can see you next week on the
lobby Chris Waters will I won't I'm
going back home to Ireland to see my
nephew and drink beer come on see you
next week JY shot here we go yeah it's
keep it doing it's going away nobody
transition away from this keep it until
it hits the obstacle keep going Point
yourself point at
yourself